welcome back to the David packman show I
am Faron cousins from Ring of Fire
sitting in for David today as he enjoys
a nice little break from all of the
insanity happening in the world of
politics so let's Jump Right In to all
of that Insanity late last week a judge
judge Arthur Inger on the one overseeing
Donald Trump's upcoming trial for the
250 million dollar lawsuit filed against
him and his kids by New York attorney
general Leticia James Ingram ruled last
week
that Donald Trump's new accounting firm
cannot continue to Shield his financial
records and they must turn them over to
Leticia James
now you may be thinking to yourself but
farron the judge had already ruled that
Donald Trump's accounting firm had to
give all of this information to Leticia
James right mazar's Donald Trump's
accounting firm was ordered to turn all
of the financial documents over they're
vital to the case
that is true so Donald Trump did what
most major corporations did and he
employed a tactic known as the Texas
two-step
typically we see it in corporations
facing billions of dollars in lawsuits
what they do is they create a new
subsidiary spin off all of the liability
but none of the money into that
subsidiary then file for bankruptcy
saying hey you can't sue us because we
got no money
now Trump's little scheme here his
version of the Texas two-step was
slightly different what he did was as
soon as the judge said hey mazars you
got to turn over this financial
information Trump said okay mazar's I'm
taking it away from you and I'm putting
it down in Texas where they have very
strict privacy laws with a firm called
Whitley Penn
and so for the last few months Whitley
Penn who now holds Donald Trump's
Financial records has been telling
Leticia James that hey sorry
under Texas law right this guy's our
client you know we love him dearly we've
known him for days we can't give you his
documents because Texas law prohibits
that
so ingeron of course was forced to step
in and say no
no you can't do that I'd already ordered
all of these documents regardless of who
held them
to turn them over and that was when the
documents were in fact by the way in my
jurisdiction here in New York they were
moved after the ruling you have no claim
to continue to hide them
so Donald Trump's financial documents
should
should is the key word be handed over to
Leticia James so that she can continue
on with her 250 million dollar lawsuit
against Trump and his kids
now
this is probably going to be appealed
that's what Trump does he he does the
delay tactic he tries to exhaust all of
his appeals so that he can make sure
he's fought as hard as he can to hide
these documents but again
when you look at the facts of the
situation while the documents were in
custody in New York they were ordered to
be delivered
they were moved after that order came
down Whitley Penn should have no legal
claim to continue to keep them hidden
because the order came while the
documents were in the jurisdiction of
the judge like it's pretty black and
white it's pretty simple I don't think
this will or could be overturned on
appeal
but we've seen some wacky things come
out of the court systems not necessarily
with regard to Donald Trump he he tends
to lose a lot throughout most of his
life
so I have every every faith that this
ruling is going to stand but it is quite
telling isn't it
Trump was ordered to turn over these
documents rather than turn them over he
decided to hide them
now I'm not on the jury I haven't seen
the documents all I can do is speculate
at this point
but if I'm looking at this case as a
prospective juror
because they will know that the
documents were moved all right this
public knowledge
I'm going to be asking myself why after
he was ordered to turn them over did he
go and hide them in Texas that that
doesn't sound like something that
somebody who is totally innocent would
do does it
again I'm not on the jury I'm not in New
York so I won't be on the jury but those
are questions
that the prosecution may ask during the
trial and those are questions that
Donald Trump's ragtag team of
second-rate attorneys are going to have
to have some pretty dang good answers
for otherwise it's only going to make
Donald Trump look guilty as hell in
front of that jury